Bob everyone welcome my name's we're
gonna play some more Tekken I'm really
excited about this game I I'm really
addicted I think it's the right word
I've been practicing my man
my only Wow look I learned a new comer I
can do this lift
hey never mind this is the one but it's
so hard to pull off gosh 60 win hell no
hell no I'm now down with that that's
fine no match for Bob I like this map
round that Warhawk is that guy wearing
white [ __ ] Lea party no he knows
grips and stuff I see no no please but
did they have it designer clothes that's
right that's [ __ ] Mike Haynie for ya
ah okay alright okay nope yeah enemy
[ __ ] thank God
don't you dare maple ba ba yeah that's
my BOB Road tell ya [ __ ] they
approached the [ __ ]
and you ever had sex with a meatloaf
[ __ ] blogs yeah dammit god dammit
please please don't [ __ ] touch me
that's right nice combo filler I'm
missing everything [ __ ] up that down
that's like that's fine don't you worry
Bob will bounce back
Bob had designer paint and Anglin is it
city everyone we're playing it think
we're playing a takeaway it's kicking
[ __ ] yes meatball Dada
mommy boss nice ball oh hell no that's
going to hit please don't kill me
please don't squeeze up ah Bob don't
liking meatball meatball attack and
you're dead you got nothing on the
Swedish meatball owned four boys you got
sixty off [ __ ] get 60 wins press well
you ain't got the part
oh please Bobby
yeah getting nervous
oh you got flanked that's gonna MIT Oh
what what no hell no Bob you loosen them
oh wow that hurt okay that's fine that's
fine
that's my mate oh oh oh oh oh hell no
hell no I don't know oh oh intense oh
okay that's that's okay
nipple that's right
[ __ ] me go ah ah ah no hey no what good
come on
yes yes it is people people you got
meatball it's finishing definite it yeah
yeah
that's my bunk we step what fun
Wow what Bob Kinsler Bob will [ __ ] you I
think I take this game a little too
seriously I might take this game a
little too seriously that's okay like I
know combination but it's so hard to
pull up look at the chase
yes pop yes it's different when it's
online to get all the pressure like all
the volume - what the [ __ ] is this
another Bob I'm the only Bob okay get
the [ __ ] out Bob
I am the Bob dumbwaiter Bob don't need a
Bob to get respect up on the street
under the Bob the beste problem will pop
a gob who peed himself a family brown
water
oh [ __ ] even sexy Bob Thank You crater
ah that's my mother that's my problem
Hey ah no are you [ __ ] kidding me
no three men get me a [ __ ] rematch no
you [ __ ] ass I hated him so much all
right Bob hey heavy in this one Joule
and hold a [ __ ] combo get that [ __ ]
out of here that's [ __ ] right
what you gonna do now huh you cowboy
looking schmuck stop Oh another well
that's okay [ __ ] sliding in my damn
Creek that's right I am the bomb round
two oh hello [ __ ] income up Oh get
the [ __ ] outta here
Hey look at that oh oh you're about to
get Bob get the [ __ ] outta here
another uh-huh oh hell no
oh hell no no wait oh you got nothing on
me
Bob finish it finish him finish him hit
that thing that's right thank you
the dome over a bobbybot Oh Hoyt this is
intense man
everything is on the land to sweaty guys
in the rain oh [ __ ] it what's up you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh look at him you later 12-bit that
mine hit oh look at this all right - man
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
that's right I am The Boss
ha ha ha I am The Boss I am The Boss
I am I am the Bob I am the real Bob I'm
The Slim Bobby yes I'm the real Bobby
all the other Bob beings can just [ __ ]
this game is gonna kill me 37 wins ha ha
no problem no problem for my man Bob Bob
man never Bob Bob got that medallion
from sucking dick good one what's the
actual [ __ ] am I looking at Brownwood
what that [ __ ] are you you're almost the
sexiest Bob Oh mom
I'm calling it safe doesn't seem to work
[ __ ] in hit yeah oh hell the thing is
I need distance we're going to do a
[ __ ] combo if im a skrub okay no
don't come on oh we're both angry what
the [ __ ] was that
hey you like meatballs I can continue if
you want I can keep going
hahaha wow that hurt you Joe please yeah
No
oh you got black ketchup [ __ ] hell yeah
that was [ __ ] awesome hey hey alright
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] believe I'm dead I'm so
dead just kidding three nice landing I
bet I would look way better in them stop
you're hurting Bob field oh never mind
ha ha ha ha ha damn it god damn it Bobby
you let me down boy drink every time I
play Bob come on I need a combo on this
[ __ ] there we go here we go Bob slide
hop [ __ ] steak
here we got food there but your corner
nevermind nevermind nevermind me okay
with the stop I don't like you I'm dead
I'm dead
[ __ ]
finish it oh don't hurt me I'm finishing
oh no yes hahaha meatball Baja 383 wings
Jesus cruel life
[ __ ] this guy no it's all countermove
yeah I got per great great just [ __ ]
great just [ __ ] just great for come on
come on hell yeah hell yeah get junk
dumb [ __ ] hey you like that combo
that's right and get the [ __ ] out of
here
another one oh that's right oh that's
right get the [ __ ] out of perfect ah
hell again oh my god I'm sweating my
nuts off [ __ ] I [ __ ] up rocky block
oh oh please oh how do I book did I do
that
oh I've come with that great job today
come on [ __ ] up too far
daddy you lose that one round was pretty
sexy 216 wins my Bob okay that's fine
not a challenge for this sexy
[ __ ] I need to find out how I
download that cowboy skin because god
damn god damn I don't I don't need Mart
if I got that [ __ ] round four okay yeah
boy what the [ __ ] was that
Hey oh [ __ ]
block my roll another one [ __ ] up oh
[ __ ] that damage
yes hey you like meatballs you like me
Paul
hey I'll ask you thank you
so do I may I can keep going buddy Oh
[Music]
meatballs oh you like this combo get the
[ __ ] outta here get the Bambaataa here
please hit [ __ ] come on come on
finishing yet come come on man you ain't
[ __ ] nog coffee stop washing my BOB oh
oh no aah
[Applause]
hey oh yes ah ah [ __ ] whoa what is
happening
Oh me bunky yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba rematch you want a
rematch
ah leave it like for Bob and remember
bob is fat